(patriotic band music)
- Hello, Yale.
- Wonderful.
So I want to introduce
that co-moderating this Q&A
will be Professor Albert Laguna,
an associate professor in
ethnicity, race and migration,
and Professor Quan Tran.
It will start with a few questions,
and then there will also
be the opportunity for you,
the audience, to pose
questions to Kristina.
All right, I'll turn it
over to you two, Quan.
- All right, thank you Diana.
Thank you, Kristina, for
that tremendous performance.
It took me on a rollercoaster of emotions,
and speaks to the power of culture,
and the power of our vote.
Very much inspired by this.
So why don't we start with just
a broad question?
If you could let us know how
your path to comedy and
performance happened,
that would be a great opening
for this conversation.
- Huh, well (laughs)
I actually joke that a lot
of how I ended up doing this
is because I could never find a...
I wasn't actually allowed
to see a therapist
when I was a kid.
It was very shameful, and so
being seen publicly was
like its own therapy.
And I actually imagined out of college
that I was gonna be a very
serious performance artist
doing dark and twisted things in galleries
and moving slowly and it would,
and long durational work.
And people would respond
to that work with,
"You're so funny."
And I was like, "That was my soul.
What was that?"
So I just began to be introduced
more and more in spaces as a comedian.
It was a very scary term to embrace
because I feel like there are
very commercial expectations
of saying you're a comedian.
There's very...
It has to look like this, and
you have to make me laugh,
and you don't have to be on all the time.
But I think
that's not true.
This is just what my comedy looks like,
and it's what it is.
And if it doesn't fit your vision of it,
go away because I'm at this
point too old to try to
wrestle with making you happy.
It's only in the last
10 years I've been like,
okay, I'm gonna tell people
I'm a comedian. (laughs)
And it means sometimes
having a conversation
when people invite me.
Can you do five minutes on a mic?
And I'm like, "Not really because I have
this whole thing I do."
But yeah, that's been the journey.
But a lot of it has came
out of coping, honestly.
- [Albert] So Kristina, I teach the class
on race and comedy, and it's a tough class
because I feel like students come excited.
We're gonna talk about comedy.
Then it's more and more
depressing as the weeks go by
as they'll get the history of
racial representation in comedy.
I'd love for you to talk about
the strengths and limitations of comedy
for thinking about,
for thinking about race.
- (sighs) Okay, so this is something
I feel like I have dealt
with in a lot of my shows,
and why I tend to gravitate
towards more theater spaces is
I think there's a patience
in a theater or gallery space
that there is not in a
commercial comedy space,
and I feel like in a
commercial comedy space
I have to play to a very
lowest common denominator,
and give my mother an
accent she doesn't have,
or you know your Chinese when.
And I feel like in theater, the reason...
Most of my shows, I feel
like the first 20 minutes
is me teaching an audience
how to watch the show and me.
And you don't really
get afforded that time.
Okay, let me very quickly sum up
why it is I'm speaking English
and why it is this is my worldview
and why it is I'm a performance artist
and why it...
This one I think I moved very quickly
and I'm hoping the audience
gets pulled along for the ride
and are not like, "Why
isn't she a doctor?"
They're stuck on narratives that they've
watched me play out.
And I don't have time for that.
I've got to tell you about
neighborhood council.
I have no time for that. (laughs)
I'm just hoping you just
come along for the ride.
But I do feel like
there's lot more prefacing
that people of color need to do
to give a little rubric
for how they're read
that white comedians
don't have to deal with.
Some people just have to
explain what a Muslim is,
or just have to explain (laughs)
just basic things that aren't taught
in the world of culture.
- Great. Thank you, Kristina.
That helped me raise the next
question in the sense that
you have characterized your
work as guerrilla performance
and a form of cultural jamming.
Could you elaborate a little
bit on these concepts,
and why you're drawn to them?
- [Kristina] Yeah, so
and this ties back into the
TV pilot that I described,
which was gonna be this
whole guerrilla thing.
But I think very much I'm
informed by the context that
I grew up in San Francisco.
I live in Los Angeles.
I had the privilege of
having been surrounded by
a lot of Asian-American
centered communities.
So for me to do things like
crash a Miss Chinatown pageant
is funny in the context of
LA Asian-American culture.
For most people, the beauty pageant queens
who are crashed on don't
find it very funny,
and the people running the
pageant don't think it's funny.
But (laughs) they get that archetype
and that I'm stereotyping it.
Now if I show up in some town
where there's no Miss Chinatown pageant,
dressed as a fake Miss Chinatown,
and I have tried this,
people get really confused,
and they're like, is this
really a beauty queen.
What's happening?
And that's what the issue was
with this show that I pitched
was I was used to making
these guerrilla projects
where I have a very specific
audience that doesn't
necessarily know the same rubric that I'm
dealing with nationally.
And truTV very much is a
flyover state comedy network,
and they're kind of sheepish about naming
certain political things, and it felt like
oh, all these things I
can do in the world of LA
are this big for my very patient
college educated audience.
But people still need to react to this and
it's almost they can't
conceive of what is she doing.
We need an explanation of
why she is like this first
before we can even watch her do pranks
because they're reading me
through a very specific lens.
So that...
So I'm drawn to guerrilla work
because it doesn't require
me getting permission to get into a space.
I love the theater, the way
people perform unintentionally.
I think politicians are
constantly performing.
I think everyone who has
a social media account
is performing.
And so I love subverting
those performances.
I think we've all...
My whole theory is we are all
realty TV stars at this point.
Whether we want to or not,
we all have the ability
to cancel or be canceled.
And it's a scary, frightening thing.
We can scream back and feel...
We can tweet back at Trump
and feel like I did something
when (laughs) maybe I didn't,
did or didn't.
But yeah, that's my interest in that work.
But I was really drawn to artists who,
as I dug through the names,
I was like, they're all white.
Michael Moore, Nathan
Fielder, Sacha Baron Cohen,
The Yes Men who do guerrilla work
and do amazing political work,
and I'm like, where are the
examples of people of color
who are able to invade
spaces in the same way
and at least get commercial recognition or
those rewards.
And I wasn't seeing it.
- [Albert] So we want to also
get the students on camera
to have you answer questions directly.
So we're gonna start with Amy.
Amy, you gonna jump on,
turn your camera on?
- [Kristina] Hi, Amy.
- [Amy] Hi.
Hi. Thank you for being here.
So my question is related
to the topic of audience.
So do you write and
perform for a particular
audience in mind, and if
so, do you consider how
intentions may be perceived differently
by other audiences who do
watch your work in good faith?
- [Kristina] (sighs) I think
about myself as an audience
member, and I would try
to write something that I
would feel proud of.
There's a certain brand of
humor that I feel panders,
and I don't want to write that.
I want to surprise myself
in the writing process
and feel like, yeah,
I'd sit and watch that,
and I'm not just delivering up
accent jokes or whatever.
I do think about the fact
that I will be touring
colleges a lot because that's
in the venues I normally tour.
That's why I don't have a 6,000 pound set
that needs to be freighted in.
That's why I sew my own set pieces
that can roll up and show...
If you give me the crappiest caf...
And this is what happened.
My other shows would have tech.
I show up to a venue,
and it's a cafeteria,
and I'm like, "Oh, boy."
(laughs) And so for this particular show,
I think I was like, "Well, I
don't want to use any video."
Then of course the great irony
is I couldn't even tour it
because of the pandemic,
and video ended up
being the actual medium.
Yeah, I do think about
what I have access to,
and the situations I'm
probably gonna be thrown into,
and how to work with those parameters.
This is one of the first videos,
of pieces in a while that has no video
because I've always had some sort of
projection or something, and I was like,
"I'm so sick of relying on
a video projector which
might go kaput on me."
But we did add some stuff
for this because we can.
We added the pictures of the dog,
and the suffragettes.
That was something that was
not part of the live show.
Does that answer?
Any more questions?
- [Quan] Along that line,
Isabelle has another question
about audience and reception to your work.
Isabelle, go ahead.
- [Isabelle] Hi, thank
you so much for being here
and performing for us.
- [Kristina] Yeah, thank you.
- [Isabelle] It's really transformed
what I thought was possible on Zoom.
- [Kristina] Oh, yay. (laughs)
- [Isabelle] So my question for you was
there is often the critique
of Asian-American artists
and comedians perpetuating anti-Blackness
through their use of African
American Vernacular English
and appropriation of Black
culture and so forth.
So how would you respond
to this criticism,
and how does it influence
your own approach
to comedy and performing?
- Yeah, that would've been a
really good question to ask me
for my last show, The Wong Street Journal.
I mean, you tell me if you...
I did track, and I
think about these things
because I read the critique articles,
and I'm like, "I don't
want to be the subject
of one of those articles."
(laughs)
But I think it's definitely something
that I've been thinking about a lot more
in my work in the last few years
because of the public conversation around.
My last show was The Wong Street Journal,
and I actually went to
Uganda and made a rap album.
You want to talk about every land mine
you can possibly fall
into for that criticism,
I was in it.
And I didn't intentionally
make a rap album.
I literally meant...
I was going to volunteer,
and I thought I was gonna
write a play about micro-loans,
and ended up meeting these guys.
And it was interesting
because hip-hip and rap
is very much an American genre
that has taken over everywhere.
I had a lot of critics who
didn't watch the full show,
but I did feel like the,
in thinking about
anti-Blackness in the show...
Someone had once called out
that using the term hella
is using African American Vernacular,
but I learned that from
Asian fobs in middle school
in the school yard.
They would say hella.
I was like, "What? I
can't use that anymore?"
It's so varied to me.
So I guess I think for me I don't know
that I can remove
everything from my language,
but I do want to at least set up in
the very critical first
scene or 10, 15 minutes
as you get to know me that
I have a certain awareness
around certain issues of race
that I am actively trying,
even if I don't get everything right,
I am actively thinking about that.
I don't know if that
answers your question,
but I do think about it.
I feel confused where some of this goes
because some of it is so...
Some of these things, which is considered
African American
Vernacular are so embedded
in how I already communicate
I think just from having lived
in the city and it didn't...
I never...
I don't know.
I don't know where it came from,
and then someone explains
that this is actually
an AAV term.
I'm like, "What?"
Yeah, I don't have a
complete answer to that,
but I do think that it is something that
comedians need to get
smarter about addressing
when they're called on it.
Yeah, that's the shift that
I hope happens is that...
I hope it doesn't mean
suddenly erasing everything in their set,
but at least recognizing
that this is coming up.
(sighs) I feel like that
was a disappointing answer,
but that's what I have.
Chayton?
- [Chayton] Yeah, question from the
acting/performance side of it.
What, to shift gears a little bit,
what differences have you found for...
I mean, I've been dealing
with this in my own work.
But what differences have
you seen for a Zoom audience
and digital for camera work versus-
- [Kristina] So many.
- [Chayton] something live,
actually being able to
hear the audience laugh?
- [Kristina] It's hard, it's hard.
Luckily, this premiered for an audience
in what was the greatest
show of my life in February.
I felt like I was in
my own comedy special.
So when shutdown happened, Diana's like,
"We could probably still do it online."
I'm like, "No."
(laughs) How are we gonna go from
all this screaming to silence?
And the pandemic wiped all
the lines out of my head,
so I had to re-watch the video
of me performing, and that helped me hear
the pauses and gaps for
laughter and anticipate it.
I'm not holding as long,
and they were long pauses.
So that helped.
But I think it's
thinking about the shift
that Diana helped direct me,
that it's not like I'm not projecting
like Kimberly Guilfoyle at the RNC,
instead of (laughs)...
It's like, hey, it's just you at home
and me at home.
It's much more intimate.
So that's the...
That has been a big blocking shift,
and the fact that rather
than clean up my house,
and pretend it's a neutral space,
is to use some of the natural
dramaturgy of the house
because we can't have a light
change or shift or whatever.
And I still have to live in this space,
so we just use it to create new scenes and
colors and shifts, and then...
And this is what my proudest thing is,
is I'm like...
I don't have to just remember lines.
I have to remember to move things.
So this is my system.
It's a chair with two Tupperwares
that I put this on.
And so it's not just
remember a line and walk.
I have to remember to move this
and (laughs) do stuff like that.
It's a different vocabulary.
I'm really glad we got
to premier it before.
I don't know what it's
like to premier a piece.
I mean, I do because I
work I'm working on this
sweatshop overlord piece, but
yeah, I think it's...
It's crazy.
I had to learn three ways to do this.
One for a live audience, one for my house,
and then we shot this on Monday
for cameras in a theater.
But that...
I also had to focus.
It was a hybrid between the
live show and the Zoom show.
Rather than look at empty
seats where no one's sitting,
I would just directly
address a big camera.
- So I think Gabriella's
next with a question.
- [Gabriella] Yes.
First off wanted to thank
you so much for this.
- [Kristina] Thank you.
- [Gabriella] I had a question
specifically concerning
your TV pilot and the
distillation of comedy
to whiter audiences.
So you noted how you had
to tone down your comedy
and have your culture
become the butt of the joke
in order to appeal to white audiences.
So along those lines, I was
wondering how you think media
and racial representation work together.
Do you think that racial
representation in media,
especially in terms of
comedy, is worth pursuing
when you have to change
it so much just to make it
make sense to white people?
- [Kristina] (groans) I think
it's a pipeline issue of power
and who's in charge.
It was clear.
I think I could've had a successful pilot
if I got to hire people who...
I mean, it was just hard.
It was all white gatekeepers
in the situation.
They were so nervous.
It was like, you know...
I think you know who I am, but (laughs)
but you're so nervous around...
It's like they didn't even like the idea
of me being too political,
and said it was a do-gooder.
They even wiped that down in the pilot.
And it was just like I think
things have to say stuff.
You can't...
(sighs) I think trying to pussyfoot around
words like feminism and stuff like that,
and just trying to pretend
that for middle America
it looks like some sort
of morpheous vague thing
won't work.
And that's what they were trying to do,
rather than name exact issues.
That it was just like,
Kristina just likes to fix
and help people.
And that became kind of dangerous,
in the sense that I felt like...
I became confused.
Wait, do I even care about this issue,
or am I Dennis the Menace
that just comes and
screws up what real activists
are trying to do here?
It was just a really confusing process.
I think we just...
We need more people of color
making decisions at the top
and making clear where tastes lie.
I feel like as frustrated as I am
that we have to go to war
with everything on Twitter,
it seems to be one of the few things
that can actually move the needle.
Like the Oscars so white hashtag
actually helped shift to get more people
of color in the Oscars in the voting pool
and stuff like that.
But it was a tough thing
when I was in that room
because it was like I can't take the angry
college activist approach
and go to war with everyone
in this room because I'm still
trying to work with them,
and they still at the end
of the day have this power.
That's what is so hard and frustrating
is I would just find myself just smiling
and going along with stuff,
and I had very few allies.
The only allies were the white women.
That was the closest thing I could find
to vet for me.
And they missed things too.
So yeah, I wish there were
more execs at the top who...
And a lot of it is those
white execs can hand hold...
Not the white execs.
The execs of color can help hand hold
the people who are like,
ooh, I don't know this,
and like, no, no, no, it's gonna be fine,
it's gonna be fine.
And that's how stuff gets moved in.
After radical cram school,
the same web series that
Alex Jones went to war with me about,
Disney called us.
We were all like, "Oh my
gosh, are we gonna be able to
buy big houses in Malibu,"
and it was the low,
the low rung folks who work with the VPs,
and they were like, "We're all about
dismantling the patriarchy in here.
This is too much, but
what else do you have?"
And I loved that.
It literally felt like
they opened the curtain,
and let the rats run through.
(laughs) And they were women of color,
but their higher ups were white folks.
So it's a slow, long process,
but it needs a...
The whole pipeline needs to shift on up,
so it's not even just the talent,
but those who make decisions.
- [Quan] Great.
Next off we have Dora
following up with a question.
- [Dora] Hi, thank you so much.
On the note of Alex Jones,
what is your best advice
as a woman in comedy
and a woman of color in comedy
on how not to give in to people like that,
how to identify whose
criticisms (inaudible).
- I mean, you think about who's
the audience you care about
and play for those crowds.
When I get invited to play
for more white spaces,
I get nervous, and I don't
turn down necessarily,
but I try to get as much
information as possible
to figure out what I'm going to present
so that it goes over well.
But I also tend to play theater spaces
because those audiences don't heckle you
(laughs) whereas some of
these other spaces will.
But not get...
I mean, I've been trolled for 20 years
since my bigbadchinesemama.com.
And I've had people send
me hate mail on and off,
and it took that.
That was the crowning moment of trolldom
for me to go, you know what,
I made it through 20 years of this.
I can make it another 20.
And if you're gonna make an enemy,
that's the enemy you want to make.
And we also, among our producers,
we were like, "What are we gonna do?
Do we respond to this?
Do we just delete stuff?
Do we hide?"
And then we were like, "Let's
shoot a second season."
So it's just like...
But it's taken this.
I don't think 20 years
I would've had this...
I guess would've panicked
and maybe just disappeared.
But I think they want you to go away,
and you have to be like...
It's a lot of self talk.
It's been a lot of self help books.
It's like I still have
to say yes to myself
before I leave the door every day,
before I want anyone to say yes,
before I expect anyone to say yes to me
or give me an opportunity.
And I have to...
You have to be somewhat
delusional in the sense like,
no, I'm just gonna do this,
and there's gonna be lots of haters.
It's a terrible use of energy
to try to bring down people's careers
and cancel people.
I actually try to avoid canceling people
as much as possible,
if I can't find a way
to be funny about it.
Yeah.
But I just go, "All right.
That's a great use of
your time, you dum-dum."
Yeah, but it's...
I understand that it's not an easy thing,
but (laughs) I guess 20 years
of building this thick skin,
I'm just like...
No one's showing up at the
house, so I'm like, "Okay, well
I guess that's okay."
Gonna lock down my info.
It also goes in waves.
They get mad for two weeks or a few days,
and then they move on to the next person
to get mad at and attack.
I know, it's so terrible.
It's just sort of like,
eh, it's what it is.
But I guess it just...
Yeah.
It just makes more work.
I'll make more shows from this that people
will probably be pissed off at.
(laughs) I'm just like, "Okay."
- [Albert] Our next question is from Khue.
- [Khue] Hi, I loved
your performance today.
- [Kristina] Thank you, Khue.
- [Khue] I was wondering if
you know the reactions of
how older Asian American
people engage with your comedy
and what reactions are elicited from them.
And if you know the one
Facebook support group
that's Asian Americans
With Republican Parents
Support Group-
- [Kristina] Oh, I
don't have one of those.
I don't have republican parents,
so I haven't had to join that.
But I love that there's a...
- [Khue] (laughs) How do you think...
Can comedy...
How can comedy be used to address
political tensions between
different generations,
especially if there are language barriers
or different...
- [Kristina] I wonder if my
mom is still in the room.
Let me see.
Hey Mommy, you want to get on?
No?
- [Gwen] Nope. (laughs)
- [Kristina] Okay, she
don't want to get on.
Okay. (laughs)
But I feel like these shows are
my most honest conversations
with my parents.
I don't know.
I know that's a crazy
answer because not everyone
invites their folks to
come see their work.
(laughs) It's funny how she got on.
That was my mother's cameo, everybody.
I don't know.
I think
how does it just bridge.
I guess you...
If anything, it's first to...
I love that the support
group is other people
with republican parents
trying to comfort each other.
So maybe you make work first
to just comfort each other.
Like, "Oh geez, why do we live with this?"
You're not gonna convert
them necessarily over night,
or get them to switch sides.
But I think there is something wonderful
in at least going, "Okay, okay.
We have each other." (laughs)
We might not have our parents right now,
but we have each other.
I don't know, but it's a community
we're slowly building of comfort.
- Thanks, Kristina.
So happy to see your mom here.
Welcome, and (laughs) it's
great to always have...
Seriously, I think I
wish sometimes that all,
for all of us in the things that we do,
we can show our parents more frequently.
On that note I think maybe
next up would be Hector
who has a question about...
Well, Hector can ask the question.
- [Hector] Hi, thank you
for your performance.
My question's more of your
influences growing up,
both in terms of maybe
professional comedians,
or influences in your family.
- [Kristina] Yeah.
My mother's actually quite
hilarious, and my father is...
He sold insurance,
but they would have these parties,
retirement parties, and they
would always do these skits.
And even when he turned 40 years old,
he lip synced a Johnny
Mathis song to my mother.
And I just think they're
actually quite funny.
Aren't you funny, Mommy?
Okay, anyway.
- [Hector] How has...
Sorry, how has your mom-
- [Kristina] I think she is. (laughs)
Just really dry things that...
I think it was advice, but I
think it was just so hilarious.
None of this advice actually
works if I'm not a dead person
hiding all the time.
I wish you'd share a
zinger with them, Mommy.
- [Gwen] No, that's okay. (laughs)
- [Kristina] Okay.
All right, okay, so (laughs)
what else?
Oh, Lucille Ball.
I loved Perfect Strangers, Mork and Mindy,
Three's Company, all
those really cheesy shows.
I grew up...
TGIF, Full House.
And then when I got to
college, I started to unleash
my angry side and was looking
at this whole side of myself
I was repressing this whole time,
and was so into this dark
slow moving performance art
where people perform in
bathrooms and draw on themselves.
There's no beginning
and no end to the show.
I was like, "Yeah, I want to do that."
And I was just really
fascinated with this genre
of work they call endurance
work or performance art.
I think somewhere between comedy and that
is where I ended up making...
I still do the show that I can repeat,
whereas a lot of these
performance art shows
you can only perform once
because you only get yourself
shot in the arm once.
You can only (laughs) shave your head
while you read a poem once.
Yeah, so I...
Yeah, I feel like it's a lot
of that, but I'm really...
I love...
The show I pitched was like
I want to do Michael Moore
meets Nathan for you.
And I want to go out and prank people,
and have that edited together
and have this amazing final
TV show moment that folks see.
- [Hector] Thank you.
- [Albert] So our next
question's from Sam.
- [Sam] Hello.
It's another question of just about
how you envision your audience.
I know this show is definitely
very focused on the US,
but a lot of your other performance work
has been around Asian Americans,
and I was wondering if you've had any
responses from Asians in
Asia or other diaspora places
and how they've responded to your work.
- [Kristina] Yeah, I'll be quite honest.
My show does not...
Or my past work, and I think part of me
had this dream of I want
to tour internationally,
and I was like, "Wow, the
Asian American identity
does not really translate
well in other..."
You've got to take it
way down and real basic.
The example I name is
Edinburgh Fringe Festival,
which is this big fringe
festival in Scotland,
and, I described them as 90s
solo shows about identity,
were doing really well there.
This is a fictitious name of a show,
but like the I'm Pakistani.
I'm Pakistani in a woman's show.
It wasn't very good.
These kind of shows are like,
these are the different kinds of...
Did you know we have different
kinds of personalities?
(laughs) These multi character shows
that I thought is not
the aesthetic that I like
went over so well there.
And I'm just like, this is so stupid.
It's like people going, "Oh,
race," for the first time.
So I did a show called Going
Green The Wong Way over there,
and the audience was like, "Who cares?"
I did bring The Wong
Street Journal to Nigeria.
That was...
Some of the audience appreciated,
those who worked for NGOs and stuff,
folks who were living in the
in between appreciated it.
Nigerians have a very
different way of watching
US theater.
They watch it like it's a music concert,
so they'll walk in and out.
At least my show.
They'll just text openly,
take selfies with each other,
and I'm still talking,
and I'm like, "Oh my gosh,
this is so stressful."
And a lot of the...
Just a lot of the context
just didn't really...
They were very nice to me,
but it just didn't translate.
So I think for this show,
I was just like, I'm fine.
I would rather play the
audiences that really
I feel like I'm myself
in and an audience can
dig in on.
And that's...
I don't need to tour
this all over the world.
I'm fine to just play this
for the context of Americans
who understand that we're in
an election cycle right now,
and that's what this was for.
For me was a show that would...
And it's a dream came true,
except it's a global pandemic
and maybe fascism coming next week.
But I wanted it to really
play in this context,
and for an American audience,
for people dealing with
voting for the first time,
which is a lot of you folks.
That's what I wanted this to be.
- [Quan] Okay Kristina,
last question for the night.
I'm sure our audience are
curious about what's next for you
in terms of performances
and work that you're doing.
- [Kristina] Oh, what am I doing next?
Sorry.
- [Albert] What other
projects you might be
working on right now, what do you got-
- [Kristina] Oh, yeah.
It's running the Auntie Sewing Squad,
which is a very different
kind of performance
in that I sewed all this stuff,
and then I, first week of the pandemic,
was like, "I'm gonna sew masks
because I'm not essential.
But if I sew masks, I'll be essential."
And seven months later, our
group is still sewing masks
which is ridiculous
because we live in America.
Why are we sewing masks for people?
But unfortunately, it's
like systemic racism.
To me it was like this
gesture of all health matters.
But then it becomes very clear that yes,
all our health matters,
but there are people
whose health is actually way worse shape
because of this pandemic,
and they tend to be
indigenous communities,
Black communities,
incarcerated communities,
undocumented communities.
And that's who we're still
working on supporting
the health of.
So we're doing this coat
drive, a warm coat drive
for Standing Rock.
I say this because you're in Connecticut
and you might have gained so much
coronavirus pandemic weight
that you have an extra winter coat.
We have an address at
aunnitesewingsquad.com.
You can directly mail
your old winter clothes
to Standing Rock.
We've just gotten really deep into this.
I was just like, this was supposed to be
a two, three week stock gap,
and suddenly hundreds of us are still
running around and collecting things
so that people don't freeze to death.
We're getting medical
supplies to Standing Rock.
We're doing relief
drives in Navajo Nation.
We sent a bunch of KN95s to farm workers
affected by the fires.
That's a project, and I
think we're gonna be here
till the end of the pandemic.
We actually have a book
deal, which is crazy,
something I would have loved in my career
outside of this,
but it had to come down
to starting a shadow FEMA
to make happen.
And then I'm working on a new show called
Kristina Wong Sweatshop Overlord,
which I hope will unfold
into a piece called
the Auntie Retirement Party.
So we've been talking about
we joke a lot as aunties
that we're gonna one day
retire and meet each other,
but it's become really clear.
It's like, yeah, we can
just retire and stop,
but the problem will still be there.
So what does it mean to actually retire
and move away from it?
I think this is a conversation
a lot of organizations
are having, especially
theater organizations that
they've been producing
shows at such a rapid pace
that they haven't stopped
to check how white supremacy
is embedded in their leadership structures
and their funding structures
and their programming decision making.
And now is this moment to
think what do we want to...
How do we want to shift forward?
And for me with the
aunties, I'm just like,
what do we do with this community of care
that we've created which
has been so powerful?
Do we continue?
Do we just walk away and that's it?
Do we exist as a cultural forest?
What does retirement
mean for a group like us?
So that's a very conceptual
piece I'm stewing on right now.
- [Albert] Well Kristina,
thank you again so much
for this performance, for taking the time
to answer our questions.
Thanks to Diana and the rest of your crew
for making everything just
feel so seamless and tight.
I can't believe you pulled it off.
I think about a performance on Zoom,
I kept asking my students
this must be tough, right?
There's a thing about Yale students.
They've all been in theater in some way
when they were in high school.
I have a thesis about that.
- [Kristina] Yeah, yeah!
That's a very Yale thing.
There's a lot of actors come out of Yale,
and come into Yale.
- [Albert] Yeah.
- [Kristina] Yeah.
- We were talking about
that, the complexity
of doing this in the Zoom.
It was fantastic.
Yeah, thanks again.
Quan, do you have any parting thoughts?
Thanks to the audience,
everyone who tuned it.
Really appreciate you taking the time
with the Zoom fatigue.
- [Quan] No, I think Diana,
you're gonna take us away, right?
- [Diana] Yeah, yes, I can do that.
Let me strike up some music.
And I think as we head out,
just want to...
The whole show is to go
encourage everybody to vote,
so please vote, vote, vote.
- [Kristina] Yes, vote.
That's the biggest thing.
- [Diana] Push everyone
who hasn't voted to vote.
Doesn't matter what for, just
get your voice out there.
- [Kristina] I have one more.
If you missed...
If you want to recommend
the show to someone,
this was the last show in
my house before elections,
but Center Theater Group is...
We've filmed it on Monday,
and it's gonna be airing
starting Friday.
It's only 10 bucks, and you get
a 30 day window to watch it.
Oh, oops, I sent it privately to Chayton.
(Diana laughs)
Sorry.
- [Chayton] I mean, I was
gonna send it somewhere anyway.
- [Kristina] But please, yeah.
This is a big experiment.
Poor theater companies right now are like,
"Are we TV networks?"
And so I'm the first fully staged show
they took a chance on.
So please sing the praises because
it's no small thing that they were like,
"You, Kristina Wong, Asian woman
whose opinions are what they are,
you're gonna be the first show
that's fully staged in this series."
I'd like to have a big gold opening,
(laughs) and show their
support for this work.
- [Diana] Yeah, and this way you can
share it with your families
if you dug the show.
This is the easiest way to
share it with everyone else.
- [Kristina] Thank you, Jared.
Thank you for your wonderful comments.
- [Diana] All right.